[Musique]
après deux ans sur Mars le rover
persévérance vient de franchir une étape
clé l'astromobile a déposé au sol un lot
d'échantillon de roche en prévision de
retour sur terre et une géologue
canadienne travaille sur la manière dont
ils seront conservés et partagez entre
chercheurs
c'était en février 2021
persévérance se pose sur notre planète
voisine mars
[Musique]
et la géologue s'en rappelle très bien
c'était un moment très excitant je l'ai
regardé avec ma famille et aussi avec
des collègues qui étaient en ligne et on
a tous célébré l'atterrissage du rover
sur la planète Mars
sa passion pour mars a commencé ici au
Musée royal de l'Ontario avec son poste
de conservatrice en minéralogie elle est
devenue responsable d'une collection de
roche martiennes
sont tombées sur terre sous forme de
météorites et pour l'instant c'est tout
ce qu'on a de la planète Mars les
étudiants et moi on les étudie pour
comprendre un peu mars mais on ne sait
pas de quelle région elles viennent
si vous prenez un morceau de gravier
dans un stationnement et que vous me
demandez son histoire comment il s'est
formé c'est difficile parce qu'il est
hors de son contexte il me manque des
informations
[Musique]
la principale mission de l'astromobile
ou Rover c'est de récolter des roches
sur Mars en notant minutieusement tous
les détails autour
son terrain de jeu c'est le cratère G0
il y a environ 4 milliards d'années
c'était un lac qui ressemblait un peu au
lac Saint-Jean au Québec à ses grands
mais peu profond et dans lequel il y a
peut-être déjà eu de la vie aujourd'hui
mars est devenu un désert et c'est en
partie la faute des volcans qui se sont
éteints sans eux mars a perdu son champ
magnétique et presque toute son eau et
son atmosphère
persévérance a donc récolté des roches
volcaniques pour comprendre pourquoi la
planète s'était éteinte et des roches
sédimentaires dans lesquels on espère
trouver des traces de vie ou au moins
les ingrédients nécessaires
ça oui Matt à la communauté scientifique
s'est rencontrée en septembre
ce qu'il fallait décider c'est si on
déposait au sol ce qu'on a récolté
jusqu'à maintenant est-ce que ce serait
suffisant d'un point de vue scientifique
et on s'est entendu pour dire que même
si c'est tout ce qu'on était capable de
rapporter ça vaudrait le coup d'aller
les chercher sur Mars
au cours des dernières semaines le rover
a déposé 10 tubes sur le sol de Mars
par une future mission un autre Rover
pourrait les récupérer mais c'est le
plan B parce que persévérance a récolté
deux échantillons à chaque endroit il en
a gardé une copie et il va récolter
d'autres
le plan a c'est d'aller les porter
directement à une fusée capable de
décoller de la surface de Mars
de relâcher la cargaison en orbite
pour que notre sonde l'attrape
fasse le voyage de retour et l'Argonne
atterrisseur vers la terre
ce sera en 2033
le rôle de Kim Tate et d'une quinzaine
d'autres chercheurs c'est de décider dès
maintenant comment s'en occuper
le plus important c'est d'éviter toute
contamination dans un sens ou dans
l'autre et aussi
si on trouve des traces de vie il faut
être sûr que ce n'est pas parce que
quelqu'un a éternué sur la roche ça doit
être un indice de vie d'une autre
planète on doit aussi protéger la Terre
parce que ses roches proviennent d'un
lieu où il y a une chance très faible
mais réelle qu'il y a de la vie
au départ les roches auront le niveau 4
de biosécurité comme le virus Ebola
celui de la covid 19 ou d'autres
pathogènes
le risque qu'une bactérie martienne
déclenche une pandémie est extrêmement
faible tôt ou tard les échantillons vont
indistribués dans différents
laboratoires parce que les chercheurs
vont vouloir les étudier avec leurs
instruments
pour ses propres travaux kimpet bombarde
des échantillons avec des rayons X et
peut voir chacun de leurs atomes la
structure des cristaux
ça lui permet de déduire la composition
du magma les températures les pressions
bref de comprendre l'histoire du
volcanisme grâce à un tout petit grain
de mars
ce que j'utilise pour mes recherches ne
se voit presque pas à l’œil nu et c'est
tant mieux
je me concentre sur des analyses à toute
petite échelle parce que je sais que
chaque grain sera très précieux
persévérance va permettre de rapporter
au mieux quelques centaines de grammes
qu'il va falloir partager entre des
chercheurs de partout dans le monde
certains de leurs travaux vont altérer
les échantillons ou même les détruire et
idéalement il faut qu'il en reste pour
les prochaines générations de chercheurs
un équilibre que Kim tahit et ses
collaborateurs doivent trouver
en tant que conservatrice je suis à
cheval entre deux mondes j'adore étudier
les échantillons mais j'aime aussi les
protéger mon rôle au fond c'est de
parler au nom des roches je veux qu'elle
puisse raconter leur histoire et nous
donner le plus d'informations possibles
passionnée par l'histoire de la Terre
est en quelque sorte devenu un casque
bleu pour les roches que l'humanité va
rapporter de la planète rouge
[Musique]